da chi arriva peso di giovani di dosso
mio libro storie paurose a scuola di
misteri e ora disponibile in libreria e
online metti alla prova il tuo coraggio
leggilo e accumula tutti i punti della
challenge nel libro
[Musica]
che succede c'è qualcuno ei
ma
questo che cos'è un baule è comparso
guida niente vediamo cosa c'è dentro
pesa tantissimo
apriamo subito
aspetta forse non è una buona idea vi
ricordate quella volta che ho perso
quella scatola la scatola del
36 a sopra
che succede c'è qualcosa di strano
c'è qualcosa dentro nessuno c'è niente
devo subito prima
a un lucchetto
non si può offrire devo trovare la
chiave allora provo a chiedere evitare
magari lui l'ha vista da qualche parte
vitale
berlino circe ora di vista la chiave da
qualche parte di questo baule ci metti
un sacco di tempo ad arrivare ogni volta
vi mangiando vero no cosa se ne fa
pensare aiuto aiuto chiedete uscito
fuori questo che cosa bella sopra è
comparsa la sopra trasferita ora ti
spiego che stavo leggendo il libro poi a
proposito lo avete preso era disponibile
in libreria online non potete non averlo
comunque stavo leggendo il libro è un
certo punto ha iniziato a tremare
qualcosa poi è comparso questo c'è solo
un problema però
mi guardavo un lucchetto non so dove
potremo centrare lo si potrebbe esserci
qualcosa di magnetico fa 100 che
dobbiamo catturare con il libro
avere a cuore i pupazzi berlino aiutati
a cercare presto
hanno queste circa
torna sopra visto che il comparto qui il
baule voi sterchele trojan che qualcosa
li sto controllando va bene nel
frattempo di questa ragazzi aspetta si
passa passa li sistemo io ma non c'è
nessuno chiave allora no qui non sembra
ci siano chiave
preso all idea proviamo a chiedere a
berlino eccessi e si sanno come si apre
questa scatola ma se c'è qualche animale
sempre arrivo aiutaci ci troviamo ha
brindato unito ha progettato che ci sia
qualcosa di pericoloso quando entrò
dobbiamo battere nello bollino per ok
marlino sembra addormentato guarda
cinese sta provando ad aprirla forse
funzionerà di carcere sta brigando usa
le tue unghie per aprire quel lucchetto
e di che si riesce quasi ad aprile c'è
qualcosa dentro ma proprio vedere
vediamo se riusciamo a capire da quasi
si vede qualcosa non riuscito a vedere
qualcosa qua dentro piccato che non
riesco ad aprirmi
dobbiamo trovare il modo di aprirla
potrebbe essere la chiave
dei suoni ma mi sentivo
non può esserci qualcuno qua dentro
troppo stretto questo spazio c'è
qualcosa che vuole uscire da qua dentro
non è uscire subito piano piano piano ho
idea se lo fa
perché no era chi vendeva proviamoci no
aspetta se ci fosse qualcosa di qua
dentro si rompe effettivamente sì forse
è meglio andare cauti
secondo voi cosa c'è qua dentro ma
soprattutto come facciamo da pivot dove
troviamo la chiave secondo voi dove
potrebbe essere proviamo a vedere tra
pagarlo ma che cosa c'entra il
lampadario sono solo maniera di studio
che luce lui all'interno dove troviamo
in genere le risposte
[Musica]
nel libro poteva consultare qualche
sfida creatura ma si cita come aprirlo
si libero da gli aprì
no questa scheda creatore non riesco a
trovare la scheda creatura del baule beh
in effetti il baule non è un ambiente è
un pezzo di rendere effettivamente fatti
abbastanza soldi per massimo l'ex per
aiutarci vi ricordate l'ex ciò detto che
sarebbe arrivato il nostro aiuto ogni
volta che lo volessimo ottima idea per
invece se chiamiamo un fabbro ma che non
riesce ad aprirlo abbiamo paura di legno
c'è anche del ferro qui e magari
riuscirà ad aprirlo lo potremo provare
noi ad aprirlo con un cacciavite o
qualcosa ma no no ci vuole il calcio
lucchetto non il cacciavite c'è il
lucchetto mica una vita
nel frattempo che vitale cerca un
cacciavite qualcosa io proprio forzarlo
dopotutto si possono scassinare
lucchetti no tipo il futuro di pirati
eccomi ho preso cacciavite allora ok
bravo noi dobbiamo portarlo prova ad
aprire quello che però è forse si era
unito qui
assassini
perché quell urlo proveniva da qua e poi
se anche arrivata per il credo che ci
sia qualcosa qua dentro o qualcuno
aspettava riproviamo proviamo ti do un
bel colpo di martello qui
ma
non possiamo portarlo ok aspetta ora che
se lo portiamo qualsiasi cosa ci sia qua
dentro si arrabbia tantissimo da allora
mi
aspetta aspetta primo così
è arrivato
e ascolta sono vitale se sei come il
genio della lampada mi puoi mostra un po
di cibo per favore
nicolò magari omogeneo e quella sui
desideri non toccarlo più ha detto
quando che ha parlato con me quindi
sfida di genio genio tomba quando
potrebbe esserci la prossima creatura
del libro che il genio del baule
quando uscirà da qui alla fine per noi
sei ragiona come possiamo fare allora
liberarlo il genio sicuramente non
dobbiamo farlo arrabbiare ok questa è
l'ultima cosa che dobbiamo fare accordi
con abbiamo aperto la scatola del
terrore poi ve lo ricordiamo
successivamente si mano fuori le nostre
paure che si può forse ancora peggio c'è
scritto non aprile quindi magari è
proprio un genio che voleva essere
liberato lo possa liberare di un
lucchetto
riconoscendo che tu sei un motivo o
qualcuno lo ha messo perché non voleva
che qualsiasi cosa ci fosse dentro
venisse liberata oppure molto pericoloso
magari è semplicemente troppo
fantastico per lasciarlo chiuso qua
dentro e non da poi dovremo aprirlo no
lasciato mi piace sotto questo video
ecco io sono pronto a coprirlo secondo
me no è meglio non aprirlo anzi facciamo
così io nasco nascosto la sotto al letto
e speriamo che prima o poi scompaia ok
chiunque si sia poi del tutti camera
mi raccomando non toccarlo ok ora vado a
fare qualche ricerca su rebound va bene
alla vita da vita
[Musica]
non aver paura pone adesso ti libero io
è vero che realizzerà i tutti i miei
desideri tipo un sacco di cibo come la
pasta le torte soprattutto alle torte
tante torte cascate di cioccolato avrei
aprile i biscotti anche i ricordi
si lo so un attimino questo lucchetto
non si apre le zone non forzarlo da qui
ha lasciati e vai e ti stavo liberando
che succede
domani stupido umano ma io ti stavo per
liberare adesso ti lascio chiusura
dentro
mi è cascato
niente stavo per liberare il genio barca
ci sia quando entra nel settore
arrabbiato tantissimo
12 io invece penso che magari
liberandolo lui si possa sentire più
libera o appunto no piuttosto che stare
chiuso là dentro lasciamolo in pace
[Musica]
ma cos'è successo
che cosa hai fatto qua stavo provando a
scassinare hai rovinato ho rovinato il
baule ho fatto solo dei piccoli segni
siamo ora ci potrebbe essere una
maledizione che si spoglia su di noi
scusa che era un baule o qualsiasi cosa
con te i continui
brucia
e non viene no non ha un progetto suo
appello
perché tutti mi amerà tin.it
piantava la risposta al libro accaduto
qualcosa lì per terra la chiave non ci
credi la chiamerà dentro al libro tutto
questo tempo era il libro apriamo
lavoravano per lo staff e brucia
aspettiamo vestire a freddi aspettatemi
libro facciamo così la tratta troviamo
può davvero vediamo speriamo che
funzioni
si
ok piano piano se proprio dobbiamo
rimanere pronti attenti vi ricordate
quando ho aperto la scatola che sono
usciti quei mostri vedevo che non esco
mostro anche da qua dentro
cosa perché no non volte lo abbiamo
forse riproviamo
aggiunge la luce ma certo è un baule un
baule antico sarà stato tantissimi anni
al buio quindi forse è meglio se
chiudiamo le tende così a meno che non
ha subito reti meno bravi in questo
chiusi si trovi ancora possiamo aprirlo
si ok ragazzi siamo pronti ad aprire
paura finalmente aperto abbiamo fatto
voi abbiamo prontissimo se poi se non
avete ancora lasciate un mi piace
passato prima di aprire paura e pensate
mi piace ora pochi pronti 3 2 1
sì
di 90 sono prima cosa libero chi
il baule tagliate le mappe so dice mani
di dosso cosa si debba una notizia ma di
signor baule stupido ma tu mi rubano no
paura ma che vuoi da me vita vuol dire
che non erano male una delle creature ve
lo avevo detto però un tratto natura ha
detto solo che è un po maleducato roccia
che puzza penso che abbia mangiato
qualcosa di morto diversi diversi mesi
fa
ma cosa ce l'ha dentro il riesco vedere
qualcosa di rosso
sai mi portò l'idea forza meglio se
rimettiamo il lucchetto e lo richiudiamo
e poi lo buttiamo da don pompe ottima
idea allora dài chiediamo subito che io
come subito così al piano non si lamenta
più doveroso adesso lucchetto e
lasciatemi si sta avviando aspetta non
si vince una maledizione
edizione emma ok meglio non richiuderlo
allora lasciamo così lontana
tendiamo vederti creatura c'è dentro e
vedere se diciamo catturarla con libro
c'è ragione come facciamo però se lui
non si vuole far avvicinare da noi che
vanno dall idea infatti sentito io lo
tengo fermo e tu lo chiudi con il
lucchetto va bene e poi ce ne
sbarazziamo ho detto che lancera una
maledizione
ok va bene proviamo partiti
emma stone è andato il baule avete visto
tu l'hai visto non mi dire che ce lo
siamo fatti scappare
cos'è una poltrona controllo
si è spostato qui come fate ad arrivare
qua ci stanno ancora la creatura dentro
signor baule
che tu sai
ma non si fa così paura di tutti per
allontanarci ci sta pure riuscendo
questa puzza
chiudiamolo ok vado a chiederlo io
ma
schiacciarci le dita e ha detto che gli
dà fastidio del sole
sembra che se palma che siamo nel mato
cercato di mediare
benlysta sì
che facciamo non è che l'abbiamo fatto
fuori poverina
si ha paura
alla luce va bene va bene riportatemi
dentro e io mi aprirò
cosa dobbiamo a guardarlo si fa buio
stretta ma possiamo fidarci secondo voi
dobbiamo fidarci di questo baule basta
non dobbiamo fidarci lo dobbiamo
lasciarlo al sole ma non scopriremo mai
cosa c'è dentro così io voglio sapere se
c'è un genio all'interno non c'è un
genio dai prezzi
non si muove più vedo che vola ci
abbiamo riportato dentro casa adesso
arti rivela i suoi segreti
mezzo fa per il di hanno insegnato che
prima di starnutire ma mi sono mai abbia
giustamente tu non c'è una mano metti un
pezzo di legno da martino allontanate
allontanati pro voglio ad aprirlo che
magari toglietegli antipatico non la fa
o spostati ok baule sono io sono anita
apriti e rivela i suoi segreti
la bacia ve lo prometto che rivestì
avessimo riportato in camera al buio
differente aperto e avresti votato la
creatura all'interno col tesi quota
cipria e ora inizia staro terzo in
faccia basta mi sono stancata di questo
baule richiudiamo lo con lucchetto e
operiamo lo presti
niente la chiave non voglio adesso così
no forse è meglio di no è un po estrema
questa cosa e dove lo mettiamo dove lo
mettiamo dove
forse meglio telos attendiamo quello
parla ma sottolinea mi
giardino guarda diciamo una di pranzo io
direi preparare da mangiare qualcosa no
l'italia è sempre il solito e va bene
andiamo principale mazzini tanto un
baule che sono quanti anni sara li
aspetterà un pochettino di più no tanto
adesso il lucchetto quindi il successo a
stare tranquilli che cosa preparare
ho dimenticato il libro
eccola qua
lucchetto
la chiave sarà vitale forse la creatura
che stava dentro al baule si è liberata
da sola vediamo
[Musica]
o no ecco perché mi ha dato
la finestra la finirete un resto
il sito non si da una finestra
c'è mancato veramente poco
red